it is going to be a little bit of a  change especially early on for everybody  to get used to Carter hits the jumper  it's Carter smooth stroke the entire  Atlanta roster combined so you make a  mistake defensively you don't come over  the top Carter a deep one of all he's  feeling it harder another deep one adds  another hit  Vince Carter putting on a show here the  Gordon file that under that category and  the Knicks defense is certainly helping  in that close Marta will try again Vince  Carter with another one on their feet  he is revisiting of insanity and the guy  paying the price for head is Julius  Randle Vince fading away